sure well I came out to the
a Bay Area back in
1997 to start working
PhD here in computer science in the
graduate program and I had become
interested in coming out to the valley
because of the fact that in my first job
at Bell communications research I was
building a ad server and I had ended up
coming out to the west coast on a
business trip once per quarter and I
figured there's a lot of interesting
things going out there going on out
there so I came out to Stanford in 1997
started working on my graduate degree
for about two years I did a lot of work
together with Dan Bonet one of the other
instructors for the course as well as my
advisor hector garcia-molina and i had
gotten distracted after the first two
years as you as you may remember back in
the late 90s the Internet boom was
taking place and so I decided to join a
startup called yodlee which at the time
had you know just a few employees I
joined as the sixth employee and over
you know spending some time away from
the graduate program here at Stanford
had seen yodlee grow to become about 200
250 employees and unlike most internet
businesses that started around that time
you'll be still around as a company but
I had after that initial time in the
stanford graduate program and at Yodlee
effectively started doing a ping-pong
between industry and academia which has
still continued today so you know after
spending some time at ye olde lee i came
back and i did finish my PhD here unlike
some smarter of graduate students like
larry page and sergey brin of google but
but nevertheless had a lot of fun I then
spent some time at Google so after
finishing the PhD here I joined Google
Iran part of their security team for a
few years and then started de cien with
with some of my co-founders you know and
you know continue to stay involved here
with the program at Stanford through
SCPD and so I have enjoyed over the past
decade plus just going back and forth
between academia in this industry I find
it to be a lot of fun to come up with
new ideas to not only write papers about
them but take some subset of those go
out and build together with you know
other folks here in the valley and you
know I love building software I love
building companies and it's just been
it's just been a lot of fun most
recently de cien has been acquired by
Twitter and we will continue the fight
against the cyber criminal community at
Twitter as we grow out there at platform
sure so you know since 2008 they CN has
been fighting all kinds of cybercrime
Jayceon had been helping websites
protect their websites against malware
infections in 2010 and 2011 in
particular de cien started helping large
ad networks protect their platforms
their ad platforms from mel vertising or
malicious advertising and it turned out
that there was a lot of common interests
that you know we had we had with Twitter
actually both de cient and twitter share
an angel investor in common so mike
maples who is known to be a super angel
here in the valley now runs a firm
called floodgate mike maples effectively
introduced the two companies and we
started chatting about you know how how
can they see in to help Twitter and we
just thought that there were so many
different ways and there was such a good
match in between the the cultures of the
companies that that we thought a more
strategic way of working together made a
lot of sense
so mobile platforms are in some ways
still in their infancy and we've seen in
the PC desktop world a whole variety of
threats that have occurred over the past
decade plus and all of those threats are
not only coming to mobile platforms but
because of the fact that mobile devices
have so much more functionality than
your average PC they have cameras they
have microphones they have GPS they have
SMS there's oh there has been new types
of abuse and there will continue to be
new types of abuse that are going to
target mobile phones and mobile
applications and this course this mobile
security course at Stanford will help
developers project managers engineers
architects become up to speed on all the
different threats that mobile platforms
face and will we hope help them create
mobile applications and mobile operating
systems that are more secure than they
have been in the past